[Music]
in can't have it old news
submitted by love from good old Alabama
Oh a new book discusses how the genius
Einstein was horrible at relationships
that's what I heard I mean super
illogical guys yeah that makes a lot of
sense yep it's gonna be a hard time we
talking about this now the whole time
yep - inside my mouth - that's good so
we all talk like this what about you -
what about you - no but you are doing
the last time just pretend like you're
doing Australian yeah exactly
I'm right I'm waiting for southern knows
new innovations to even mess with women
all right all right he didn't have that
time you got you got half only get in
hair cuz you're you're chewing on some
live or do you really have a fire planet
the character okay well you're like a
method actor so you really have dip got
it watch out Daniel day-lewis we're
coming for you you just when did you
even put it in exactly he's frozen it's
an art installation it's an art
installation what's happening look so
grateful I gotta give you a pound for
that Oh quick quick on your feet quick
on your feet yeah good job
it's okay cuz I still have a girlfriend
and she loves me still for you she must
really love you dude she might be small
too so it's a perfect fit just cuz
you're big does it mean you have a big
vagina alright well science
cuz he's saying that she's small so
small vagina but I'm like the opposite
yes there's this book called Einstein
his life and universe by Walter Isaacson
and he describes how Albert Einstein I
just do not have a very good time
keeping his love life intact cause he's
too busy [ __ ] thinking about bigger
[ __ ] I'm sure the same holds true with
like Picasso and all these other people
that are like busy figuring things out
or crafting stuff right when they start
fighting a new pilot Ted man I'm trying
not to fight over the toilet scene no
more dude I got bigger should deal with
mmm like I'm trying to figure out like
gravity rules and [ __ ] quantum physics
all that stuff you see gravity gravity
rules not me like scientists know just
like yeah I'm sure mathematicians other
mathematicians same thing they didn't
probably go on dates they probably just
locked themselves in a room for for
their whole lives
yeah saw his first wife leva Marik she
was also a fellow scientist and
mathematician they were married for 11
years okay a long time and so they had
two maybe three kids because one of the
kids there's like rumors like who knows
if this kid exists but anyway they had
two boys so during the end of their
marriage
Einstein came up with this list so they
can salvage the personal relationship
and still stay together for the kids so
not really being intimately as like
husband and wife anymore but more like a
partnership yeah and so he gave this
list of demand and so first of all I
said you will make sure that my clothes
and laundry are kept in good order that
I will receive my three meals regularly
in my room mm-hmm that my bedroom and
study are kept neat and especially that
my desk is left for my use only very
reasonable so far very reasonable yes
you will renounce all personal relations
with me insofar as they are not
completely necessary for social reasons
specifically you will forego my sitting
at home with you am i going out or
traveling with you you will obey the
following points in your relations with
me you will not expect any intimacy from
me nor will you really get announced on
deck you
so funny you will stop talking to me if
I request it but you will leave my
bedroom or study immediately without
protest if I request it here which it's
a good point you will undertake not to
belittle me in front of our children
either through words or behavior I just
imagined this fly the typewriter is
[ __ ] fluffy hair just [ __ ] swing
around like you will not make fun of me
in front of the kids
yeah not even sound like a relationship
no intimacy fascist wash my clothes
looks like Pablo Escobar god bless you
you know what's hilarious is you know
the Nikola Tesla yeah he was in love
with the pigeon like a bird that's
gangster dude what's gates are about
that I don't know it's so weird this why
not [ __ ] out I'm interested in women
no no it was like like a real now it's
like when you love a puppy but then he
was obsessed with the pigeon but a
pigeon or just pigeons a pigeon like a
special Tiffany that he thought that he
had a connection with okay she probably
communicated with it telepathically
maybe he put some Tesla coils in her and
[ __ ] oh yeah oh whoa I just think anyone
that's super smart or creative it's just
sometimes the brain can I think it's go
into other areas that we can't see yeah
so it's just like that's no excuse to
treat another person like that though
you know I mean no I justify about
they're just what would you do Clark put
those limitations on your relationally
you can't do this can't do this oh yeah
we wouldn't be together
exactly unless I put my own limitations
on him and I say well whatever I want
what about you Sam I guess I mean that's
the most reasonable answer like unless
it's both ways yeah yeah we also don't
understand the context of this time cuz
like that might be normal like yeah it's
not yeah it's not right but then back
then you know there were different rules
like cause like if women's jobs were
just to work the house then you can say
like you're not doing your job right
because it's like this this is not work
it's like a different conversation we're
like now it's like
that's [ __ ] up if you tell someone no
intimacy that [ __ ] that's what a
relationship is right missing me divorce
was probably frowned upon
yeah they don't divorce back that it's
the air stuff yeah you just stuck so
it's like how do you work within that
world yeah well the only lasted a couple
months and that's when she decided to
leave him oh you can't go and well they
still divorce but it was really frowned
upon
yeah it's not respecting the bill he
ended up getting with his first cousin
after I heard about that [ __ ] weird
first cousin is a little Wow that's too
close
yeah it's called incest that's incest
yeah that's like [ __ ] a brother dude
yeah Megan is like okay I think
biologically it's a little bit safer
it's so weird but what second cousin
yeah that's so weird
what's which cousin do you prefer the
first second third or yeah none anywhere
close to a tree no no no no it's got to
be separate but what if they were fine
no what girl fine it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter family is family is
family is family you don't cross that
line no but what if you never met this
cousin no Joe and your your Joe you're
you're 30 years old she's 25 fights the
fight is the first time and she's mixed
and she doesn't even look Asian she's
like half white half asian stand your
ground Steve fine ass boy no no no
double double absolutely not
have you seen an old boy yeah he didn't
know he didn't know never knew but then
like you end up falling in love before
you know and then you find out would you
break up oh god I would need to use a
therapy after that I'll be happy you
would you know how hard it is a fine
love in this world ain't no tonight try
to [ __ ] my sister [ __ ] no but let's go
back to the robots the robot cousins No
even if you had the finest second cousin
they need to be like you know what I'm
gonna throw bomb nobody wants to do it
nobody I mean everybody but I definitely
want to do it okay so here this is what
I mean by that nobody wakes up and says
I want to fall in love with my cousin
that's not what happens it just happens
yeah yeah it's kind of like oh I met
this girl out of wedding she's really
hot she's like a friend of a friend
guess what
she's your cousin oh look dude it's like
well we've been dating for ten years
it's like those twins separated at Birth
from Africa and then they met each other
in America and they started dead a
connection yeah that a really strong
connection cuz you were dodging me too
and then they realized oh my gosh you
have the same parents yeah man would you
if you cut what are your cousin's
sniffing through your panty drawer I'm
[ __ ] by your reaction to everything is
I'm gonna punch someone
what if someone got your last name wrong
well I'll point you in the face with my
left hand because that's like the softer
one okay you're considerate you're kind
of considerate what have you got someone
drinking their [ __ ] coffee you would
do it didn't you like if you had a fine
second cousin never heard that sentence
ever
you got that if it's after the fact like
I've been dating this person I'm about
to get married to this person we've been
together for so long already and then
someone drops the ball goes by the way
they're family I'm like oh [ __ ] doesn't
change the way I feel about someone
family's about to get tighter right but
then it's like no I don't think I go oh
look like I'm at a family reunion my
cousins looking [ __ ] fine by that
time if I know they're my cousin they're
not even in mine we need someone though
that did that right I knew someone that
did that was hunting for their family
but he would tell me every time we go to
their family's house he would tell me
that he wished his cousin wasn't his
cousin so that he wouldn't get tempted
Jesus she should've just [ __ ] her then
if I if I knew already I'm like
hmm I'm not sticking my dick in her or
him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]